hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remembered so you don't have to there is
no doubt about it The Simpsons has
defined a generation of humor
it was slick it was clever it was
satirical it had unforgettable
characters and it left its mark forever
on television history clearly it was
ahead of its time
and taken off the air far too early and
it was still on air today I'm sure it
will continue to inspire and challenge
all of the masses out there goddamn it
it's still on yes like most people I
really wish the Simpsons would just up
and die so we could talk about what a
great impact it had on comedy as opposed
to asking why the hell they're beating a
dead horse with another dead horse but
either way we still end up saying the
exact same thing wasn't The Simpsons
funny and the answer is yes yes it was
despite the fact that they've more than
overstayed their welcome we still can't
forget what an entertaining quotable and
hilarious impact the show has had on us
it's one of the most influential shows
in that it helped form so many people's
sense of humor so many of us today get
our delivery our writing are performing
and just our straight-up sense of comedy
from the genius that was The Simpsons
but again I must ask which one's had the
biggest impact which ones were the most
memorable meaningful or just downright
funny
well let's travel back to Springfield l
could choose since this is the top 11
best Simpsons episode
[Music]
numberland deep space Homer just the
title alone invites so many
possibilities and the Simpsons take
advantage of all of them
I mean think about it Homer in space
this is God to build up a lot of good
jokes and it does NASA's ratings as well
as their funding is going down the
toilet so they decide to find the
everyman to send up into space to get
more viewers the results are Barney and
Homer resulting in every kind of joke
you can imagine out of these two drunk
jokes real iteration of the training
there'll be no more beer read all weeks
with only wine exercise jokes there once
was a man from Nantucket movie jokes the
only danger is if they send us to that
terrible Planet of the Apes
they even got Buzz Aldrin to guest star
isn't that great to hear one of the
first men on the moon say careful
they're ruffled the jokes range from
visual to verbal to story-driven
to character based and just about all of
them hit bull's eyes they showed us
exactly what we want to see with this
setup and had us laughing all the way
through
[Music]
number ten
Ichi and Scratchy and marg this feels an
issue that is still being argued about
today how much of violence in our youth
is based on media in this episode Meggie
imitates a stunt she saw an itchy and
scratchy and enters homer on the head
when Marge sees where it came from she
starts an all-out war with the cartoon
makers at first they ignore her but
after while she gains quite a following
enough that the producers feel they have
to change their product to a friendlier
image the kids don't like it anymore and
partake in a revolutionary idea going
outside everything seems surprisingly
peaceful until a tour of Michelangelo's
David comes into town and all of Marge's
followers want her to protest it but in
reality Marge sees it as a work of art
which leads to a perfect crossroads of
freedom of speech and censorship
well what do you have to say all those
Marge Simpson wannabes out there who
wish to suppress David's total but what
makes this episode so great is that it's
not directly attacking freedom of speech
or censorship it basically shows that
whichever choice you make there's always
going to be consequences
in reality they leave the choice up to
you is it better than a silence
expression and free will in the hope for
the greater good we're let freedom ring
despite the fact that most of what we're
giving people is garbage it doesn't take
a side it instead attacks everyone which
is when the simpsons rioting was at its
best in the end there are no clear
answers but there are a lot of
interesting issues for a show that was
certainly controversial when it came out
it would have been very easy just to
throw together an episode where they say
screw censorship but instead they took a
very clever very adult and very
thought-provoking angle not bad for an
episode that mostly features a cat
getting horribly disfigured
[Music]
not homers enemy this is easily one of
the darkest episodes The Simpsons have
put out and I'm not gonna lie that's
what makes it so enjoyable we're
introduced to a man named Frank Grimes a
genius mind who had no brakes in life
was met with nothing but misfortunes and
never had anything handed to him he gets
a job at the power plant where he comes
across Homer Simpson
obviously the exact opposite everything
was handed to him he has no idea about
sacrifice and is as dumb as well Simpson
Grimes is horribly confused / enraged
that such a man can exist and wants to
prove to Homer the world and himself
that this is not how life works people
have to answer for their consequences
and take responsibility for their
actions but home words actions
constantly have no punishment actually
they do except it's often given to
Grimes stay the hell away from me
because from now on we're enemies do I
have to do anything oh the more more
Grimes tries to expose Homer for the
fraud that he is the more and more Homer
is rewarded and Grimes is punished again
they could have made Grimes just the
straight a bad guy but honestly you
really sympathize with him
why are sometimes good smart people
punished and bad stupid people rewarded
I've had to work hard every day of my
life what do I have to show for it this
briefcase and this haircut and what do
you have to show for your lifetime of
sloth and ignorance
what do car is a beautiful wife son who
owns a factory fancy clothes and
lobsters for dinner it's just him trying
to get some clarity in life and him
obviously receiving no answers or at
least none that make any sense I guess
you could argue with sort of a leave
good enough alone story but the ending
is so dark and closes on an image that
is downright mean-spirited that it
reaches major uncomfortable levels at
Simpson episodes go and you know what
that's kind of funny once in a while
sometimes we need something really harsh
and mean to mix it up with all the
shrugging happy endings we get so much
and this one is definitely an enjoyably
unpleasant episode I mean even for a
Simpsons episode the ending is
shockingly aggressive it's sort of like
the No Country for Old Men of the show
you know you just watched something
disturbing but if you even worse for
having enjoyed it if you lived in any
other country in the world you'd have
starved to death long ago he's got you
there dad
numbering Cape Fear this is one of those
episodes everyone keeps bringing up and
for a while I didn't get why it's funny
you don't get me wrong but why do so
many people always pick it as one of
their favorites well watching it again
I found it's not just funny it's really
funny being the third appearance of
Sideshow Bob this was the first time he
did have a diabolical scheme for power
lined up but instead just wanted
straight-up vengeance on his
arch-nemesis Bart Simpson it was
actually one of the first times you saw
Bart in real peril like someone was
actually trying to murder him and it
came from the perfect person you'd want
to see try to murder him I guess from
that angle it's pretty cool I mean we
have seen this confrontation building up
for several episodes and they delivered
it just at the right time you know
before it became every other season but
on top of that practically every joke
works in this episode
big or small visual or verbal it's hard
to think of a scene that didn't make me
laugh out loud at just the absurdity of
it remember this gem this is dedicated
to Bart Simpson with a message I am
coming to kill you slowly and painfully
how about this one
hey kids wanna drive through that tag
dispatch no whoop do again one a need we
forget throw in a clever knockoff of
Cape Fear and you have a damn funny
episode with lots of laughs that pale
number seven Homer at the bet again
sometimes just putting a character in a
certain scenario is all you need
Homer playing baseball boom the jokes
just write themselves
mr. burns starts a softball team to
which Homer seems to do surprisingly
well with all because of what he claims
is his magic bat but once burns makes a
million-dollar bet with another power
plant team the game is on to cheat like
nobody's cheap before he gets some of
the greatest baseball players of all
time on his side and forms the ultimate
super force what makes this episode so
good is not only the writing but also
the fact that they actually got these
players to do the voices they even
managed to give a lot of them sort of
comedic personalities like Darryl
strawberry's a kiss-ass Steve sax is a
beep and Ozzie Smith is trustingly naive
you know with all these people to juggle
though they still keep the focus on
Homer never losing track that is still
his story all the players are funny
memorable all our characters are funny
and memorable the conclusion is
something of a perfect anticlimax and it
ends on one of the funniest stills of
the show it's an all-star cast with
all-star jokes what's not to love we're
talking home
ah see and the strong number 622 short
films about Springfield a lot of people
complained that The Simpsons episodes
don't really have a flowing narrative in
fact the story they start off with often
has nothing to do with what they end on
well in this episode they just go for
broken straight up show the lives of
Springfield and their day-to-day
troubles we get a few minutes with Lisa
a few minutes with Smithers a few
minutes with dr. Nick a few minutes with
Homer we even get a few minutes with
bumblebee man surprisingly what I do
like about this episode is that they do
sort of connect like Lisa will be chased
by bees so we follow one of those bees
to smithers he gets stung and goes to
the hospital where we see dr. Nick is
going to work he ends up draining the
power which leads to the lights
flickering in a nurse story and so on
and so forth
so each story very loosely does come
together they even make fun of the fact
that they're telling the story in such a
strange way that they even make a few
pulp fiction Elisha's it's great just to
see the characters do what they do and
not necessarily have to be bound by a
three-act structure all the time as well
as a happy ending sometimes the jokes
and characters can simply come from the
jokes and characters I think the only
nitpick I have is that while they did
connect a lot of stories together they
never did connect it through the
commercial interruptions and that really
annoys me because it's like the
commercials just get in the way of every
thing number five Marge vs. the monorail
this is another one where the comedy is
just ah when I think of an episode that
just had a ton of energy a ton of music
and a ton of jokes this one often pops
in there
Springfield comes into a ton of money
and there's a town meeting held about
what to do with it
a con artist recommends building a
monorail never giving away that he plans
to buy cheap faulty parts and keep the
rest of the money for himself and he
recommends it in probably the most
amusing of legs and I swear they're at
Springfield's only choice throw up your
hands and raise your boys
[Music]
again this leads to a lot of great
possibilities like home or being the
conductor I go the big one baby a lot of
the characters getting on board
discovering what happened to the
original monorail even somehow working
Leonard Nimoy into one of his strangest
cameos know the world needs laughter it
has a song number it has action it has
great character based jokes it just has
hit after hit after hit and each one
continues to get a bigger laugh after
the next there's nothing much else to
say about it except mono Homer the great
we all like to fantasize about another
world we don't see where people get more
privileges than the everyday common
person well this is the Simpsons take on
it not only is it funny but the layout
of the story is just friggin perfect
Homer stumbles across an ancient order
of the Stonecutters an organization that
really doesn't do anything except keep
secrets and reward itself what that
sticker on your car so you won't get any
tickets
and that's not the one keeps paramedics
from stealing your wallet won't work on
you oh wait don't bother call 9-1-1
anymore here's the real dublin hmm
that's pretty funny Homer manages to get
in but gets a big trouble when he
accidentally destroys their sacred
parchment that's also pretty funny they
discover a birthmark on him though and
it indicates that he is the chosen one
said to bring balance to the
Stonecutters and he of course diffuses
the power like mad that's really funny
but then it turns out he is the chosen
one when he starts to feel bad and takes
on some responsibilities by helping the
community only to find that the
Stonecutters don't want ballot and
instead want to go back to getting drunk
and doing nothing and the way they get
out of being Stonecutters I won't dare
ruin for you here but let's just say
it's a perfect book into a perfect joke
and a clear sign of how stupid and
immature the whole idea of privileged
organizations can be it's another one of
those that just has great joke after
great joke many of them ranging from
very creative to just bizarre like
remember who makes up the stonecutter
High Council how the hell did they even
come up with
people well if you don't know what I'm
talking about give it a watch and find
out what you've been missing thank you
[Music]
Lisa's wedding
The Simpsons have done a lot of what if
future episodes but by far the funniest
and probably the most heartfelt is
Lisa's wedding this is the first time
you feel like this is what the Simpsons
would really be doing several years down
the line
Bart's a construction worker Lisa's top
of her class and Maggie apparently is a
blabbermouth gossip and yet we still
never hear her talk that is friggin
genius but it's more than just showing
us their future cells is following the
story of Lisa meeting another student
and falling in love once he proposes the
rest of the episode is the groom trying
to fit in with the family but hopelessly
being disturbed and terrified by them
it's a good episode because not only is
it funny but it also shows Lisa's
connection to her roots and the fact
that she can be annoyed by them but
still not even flinch for a second about
how much he loves them is really quite
touching on top of that the groom is
actually pretty entertaining character -
it would have been easy just to make him
a generic jerk and granted they'll make
it the nicest guy but they had you to
give them a few funny lines and a few
good scenes to work off Oh an English
boy yeah you know we saved your ass and
we're glad - yeah well we saved your ass
in World War 3 as Joe but of course we
love seeing what happens to these people
in the future mr. burns Krusty Lenny
Carl every reveal gets a big laugh it's
also funny seeing our cute little
innocent child character soon we get
some more adult jokes you didn't have a
bachelor party we had one in his honor I
had one in his honor I went to a strip
club
throw on top of that a touching story
with great character and you have one of
the Simpson's finest
[Laughter]
number two the Halloween episodes yeah
yeah I know it's at she'd but hey if I
was to judge the Halloween episode show
by show they take up half of the list
they're that good the Halloween episodes
are a great excuse for The Simpsons to
do whatever they want you know but
before they start doing whatever they
want they were darn they were creative
they were satirical they were gory they
were cute they were poignant they were
stupid they were all just tiny little
masterpieces Plus who doesn't look
forward to those aliens every year what
happened to us kudos quiet you even with
the last few Halloween episodes not
being so great you know you're still
gonna watch him we know they're worth
looking at because even when you have to
sit through the groaners the bull's eyes
are still worth them even the worst
Halloween episode has something to
admire they satirize everything from TV
to movies to literature to urban legends
I suppose if I had to nitpick I'd say
the one downside is that the specials
used to be tied together by something
representing a narrative like somebody
telling a story or someone having a
dream something like that I don't miss
those but at the same time I do
acknowledge it would be very tricky
every year to come up with new ways to
tell these shorts so I do understand but
when you get down to it that's not what
we're here for we are in fact here for
the shorts even at its poorest there's
always something entertaining or
creative and the Halloween specials
never disappoint on that front gothic
gross and just going all out the
Halloween episodes are always a fave
[Music]
now before I get to number one I want to
point out that this is all opinion we're
gonna hate it aren't we
everyone has their own different take on
things a real bad one isn't it
what you might like I might not what I
may like you made it alright I'll just
show it and the number one Simpsons
episode is Bart gets an F now I know
what you're thinking wait a minute the
first episode of the second season is
not just the one where Bart keeps
failing I don't remember that one being
especially funny why is this one so
special well there's several reasons why
I think this is the best episode first
off it was the beginning of the new
animation style the Simpsons weren't as
rubbery or dead I'd like in the first
season now they seem much more flowing
controlled and alive so that was a big
deal second this was a huge stepping
stone in terms of writing The Simpsons
identity was finally starting to evolve
into that fast aterial type way of
telling jokes in the first season it was
pretty slow and clunky but here this is
where that great Simpsons speed finally
starts to take off but even that's not
why I consider it the best episode we're
used to seeing Bart get bad grades
yeah whatever he's a troublemaker as
part of the territory but in this
episode it finally starts to add up they
have a real talk with him much like how
real parents and real teachers talk to
kids as well
Bart has failed his last four exams in
history is there anything you're not
telling us okay okay why we dancing
around the obvious I know it you know it
I am dumb okay does the post think I'm
happy about it as shameful and as
emotionally crippling as it may be I'm
afraid my recommendation is for Bart
Simpson to repeat the fourth grade what
you can tow me back I'll do better I
promise
okay there's suddenly something at risk
and something Bart values is now truly
on the line so what he buckles down
works hard and everything is fine right
actually no he finds he has trouble
focusing can't remember any facts and is
constantly distracted by the world
around him he doesn't give up though he
tries hard almost to the point of
torturing himself even prays to God for
things to work out but in the end
despite all this efforts
reality takes its toll well Bart it's a
59 that's another app no I can't believe
it and in my opinion this is the saddest
fucking thing I've ever seen in this
show I identify a lot with this episode
I wasn't a very good student growing up
either and I can tell you all the talks
all the pressure all the fears of
failure are properly represented here in
my opinion this is the most dramatic
episode they've ever put out there's no
villain there's no one element of blame
it's just a tough slice of life and a
show is that you can still try your best
and not necessarily succeed which is a
hard lesson for anyone to learn so hard
that they don't even really teach it
that much in TV or movies it's tough to
deal with in this episode doesn't
sugarcoat it it shows just what impact
it has on him and how much it can really
hurt now true there is still a happy
ending but to be fair I think it kind of
works his hard work does have some
payoff and he uses what he went to his
advantage but this is the first and in
my opinion only time the Simpsons had a
perfect mix of good comedy good
storytelling and surprisingly good drama
I've never seen an episode that balanced
all three of those so well you get
sucked into Bart's dilemma you feel bad
for what he's going through and you want
to see him come out okay on top of that
there's still some good laughs a lot of
heart and a satisfactory resolution
although I will say if his big concern
is not repeating the fourth grade then
how come in every single episode he's
still in the fourth grade I don't know
but what I do know is that this is a
truly unique episode and in my opinion
the absolute best of them all it's
touching it's funny it started the style
that were the most familiar with with
The Simpsons it's just a gem
[Music]
John Hancock's
writing his name in the snow what a game
you played based on the sim
ma no don't